All right, let's hit the headlines.
First up, we have got to talk about pop star, Meghan Trainor
and her bathroom.
What?
Because it's the story everybody's talking about.
It really is everywhere.
If you're on like Instagram or social media,
this is the story that keeps coming up.
Glamor reports that, Megan says she and her husband,
actor, Daryl Sabara have side-by-side his and her toilets.
That's right.
(Ross and audience laughs)
She says they number one together all the time
but as far as number two,
they've only tried that once.
Oh God.
Yes, this is what they're saying.
So let's discuss.
Chelsea, Ross thoughts.
Oh God.
(audience laughs)
I like that they've only tried number two once.
It's like, exactly.
(audience laughs)
They're not gonna try that twice.
No, you don't go back for more of that.
No (laughs).
I'm a romantic so I'm trying to find the-
A separate bathroom.
No, I'm trying to find-
(audience laughs) (audience applause)
Yes.
I'm thinking, is there something sweet about this?
I mean, you're sitting there
or standing there and you turn to your partner
and you say, 'You're my number one.' (laughs).
(Drew and audience laugh)
Is there something sweet about it?
Yeah, I mean, I love Meghan,
so I wanna to support her in her decision making.
I don't think I need to do that.
I feel like you can feel the effects
of that just by living in close spaces.
That you don't need to drive that point home.
Totally.
But I am the biggest Meghan Trainor fan,
and she is a Nantucket girl.
I am obsessed with her.
Meghan, please come on the show.
I love you so much.
I am cheering you on always. I am.
Yeah, except for this whole two toilet things. Girl no.
Call the contractor it's gotta go.
I think she's gotten the message loud and clear
at this point.
I think she put this out there.
That's what I want, come on the show
I wanna ask you, 'Are you glad you put this out there?'.
I just think this is sort of a crappy idea. All right.
(co-hosts and audience laugh)
All right, next another love story.
And this one's a little bit different.
It comes from Oprah Daily,
Jim who's 78 and Audrey who's 79 met last fall
on this website called Silver Singles,
for people dating over 50 years old.
Jim was new to it and his wife had passed in 2017.
And Audrey, she'd been on it for years with no luck.
Well, guess what?
They were a match, 94% match.
So they spent the first 10 nights just gabbing on FaceTime.
I guess they asked their grandkids how to FaceTime.
(audience laughs)
And then they moved on to COVID safe dating.
And three months later, they moved in.
And five months later,
Jim proposed with his mom's 1939 art deco ring.
And last month lovebirds,
they were married in front of friends and family.
And for their honeymoon, they say,
they're gonna stay in
and watch their favorite detective shows.
Oh God, can I marry you?
(audience applause)
(Chelsea laughs)
I have to tell you, my grandma,
after my grandpa passed away,
her boyfriend from elementary school,
at 91 tracked her down.
And until Harv passed away, they were sort of courting.
And they found romance again at 91.
And I remember thinking,
if I ever find myself old and single,
I'm going to leave a little tray
next to that side of the bed for somebody's dentures,
just in case,
because you gotta keep the hope for love alive.
Don't you think?
Well, I guess the next question for these two is,
what their toilet situation is.
(Drew laughs)
Let's see what's keeping their love alive.
(Ross laughs)
I love when elderly people find love.
What an inspiration for everybody.
It's so sweet.
What's it called, Silver City Singles?
Silver Singles. Thanks so much.
Silver Singles (laughs)?
By the way it should be called Silver City Singles.
I take umbrage with 50 is a silver single.
Yeah. That part.
We take umbrage with it
'cause we're about to round the corner of that number.
Exactly.
When we were young, It's like 50 is so old.
Now we're like 50's the new 20.
(Drew and Ross laugh)
What about you, Chelsea? Would you ever consider marrying?
Well, I take a lot of pride in remaining, not married.
I just feel like it's an antiquated notion
and it's a structure set up by what,
I just feel like it's outdated to be quite honest.
Well fair, but you have changed your mind
about a lot of things as you've grown.
I'm sure I'll get married next week or something.
Every time I say I'm not gonna do something,
the next week, I'm like, oh, here I go.
I said a few years ago, I'll never write another book.
And then the next week I was like, okay,
I'm ready to write a book.
So I think I just have to say, I'm not doing something
and I'll do it.
So you can't rely on me for the truth
about my own situation, is what I'm getting at.
They say, never say never.
Well, you're a good at marrying. You like it.
I've got three.
Would you ever get married again?
Never ever. It doesn't work for me.
It's like I've tried it. No.
I would also like to add that
I would like to send a message to all women
and all people really, that are growing up that,
that doesn't make you valuable.
You know what I mean?
Being married doesn't give you an identity
that you didn't previously had.
I think it's a really strong stance to show people
that you can have it all, you can be in love,
You can have success, you can have your career
and love your family.
And there doesn't have to be a label to it.
Completely, you can define what love and happiness
and successes is for you.
Yeah. So I think that's important,
especially for young girls.
I love that.